lors de son allocution télévisée mardi
soir le président de la république a
affiché son souhait de casser à la
racine les chaînes de contamination en
ciblant davantage les cas contacts et
les personnes testées positives au
coville 19 je souhaite que le
gouvernement et le parlement prévoit les
conditions pour s'assurer de l'isolément
des personnes contaminées y compris de
manière plus contraignante
dans la foulée des parlementaires du
groupe agir ensemble qui fait partie de
la majorité présidentielle à l'assemblée
nationale ont déposé une proposition de
loi le texte vise à rendre les allemands
plus strictes tout en intégrant des
compensations financières
l'article 3 rendrait obligatoire
l'isolément des personnes positives au
coville 19 et des cas contacts tout en
sanctionnant son non respect selon les
informations rapportées par plusieurs
sources journalistiques l'amande
pourrait s'élever à 1500 euros en cas de
manquement et une gratification de 30
euros par jour pourrait être accordée
aux personnes contraintes de s'isoler
le porte parole du gouvernement a
apporté quelques précisions lors de sa
conférence de presse à la sortie du
conseil des ministres sur la dimension
de la protection et donc de l'isolément
l'objectif est d'être plus efficace
c'est à dire que les règles soient mieux
comprise sans doute nous expliquer sans
doute expliquer de manière plus forte y
compris en présentiel en se rendant au
domicile de personnes qui sont
contaminées pour les accompagner et
qu'elles soient plus effective possible
le mans en étant contraignante avec une
obligation légale et possiblement si on
pousse le raisonnement une sanction pour
garder là aussi ce qui se fait chez nos
voisins dont un certain nombre de pays
qui nous entourent si ce n'est la
majorité des pays qui nous entourent
il ya aujourd'hui une obligation légale
à s'isoler c'est vrai que plusieurs pays
européens ont déjà pris des mesures
similaires en italie en allemagne et
royaume-uni ceux qui ne respectent pas
les allemands peuvent être verbalisés
les montants s'élèvent jusqu'à 5000
euros et peuvent atteindre des sommes
bien plus importantes en cas de récidive
en espagne par exemple
cette somme peut atteindre 600 mille
euros pour quelqu'un qui aurait enfreint
à plusieurs reprises
l'obligation dit
seulement en france un débat
parlementaire devra donc fixer les
détails de ce dispositif sur la table
depuis déjà plusieurs semaines
dispositif qui semble être un objectif
de l'exécutif dans le cadre de sa
stratégie de déconfinement